qu'il faut il faut être ferme et faut
pas être obtus je pense qu'il ya un
hiatus dans ce que monsieur macron
incompris de son élection
quand il dit je fais ce que je dis très
bien et fait ce qu'il dit mais il faut
quand même toujours se rappeler que 24 %
de français qui ont voté pour lui au
premier tour et au deuxième tour il n'a
pas été élu pour ce qu'il a proposé
il a été élu contre madame le pen
donc par rapport à ça il faut pas se
dire je fais toute la politique que
j'avais annoncé avant le premier tour il
faut faire une politique qui rassemble
l'ancien cette réforme ferroviaire pour
l'encourager à tenir bon
je pense qu'il faut il faut aller au
bout de la réforme parce que de toute
façon si le gouvernement arrêtée en
cours
je pense que pour notre pays ce serait
une catastrophe pour les ré les réformes
à venir
ça veut pas dire que je bénis
complètement la réforme et à partir du
moment où elle est engagée dans une
réforme et qu'on considère qu'elle est
bonne pour le pays soit les pas bonne il
faut l'arrêter
elles soient les bonnes et il faut
essayer d'aller au bout